This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There are a lot of beautiful places in California, downtown Oakland, for example. But Santa Barbara is like stupid beautiful. Yeah, it's like a comically picturesque California scene here. A few months back we sent producer Emmett Fitzgerald down to Santa Barbara on a really taxing reporting assignment. We've got all these beautiful sailboats, you've got pelicans, you just saw two dolphins, the sun's beginning to set. It's a rough life. Oh, here comes a wave.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。加州有很多美丽的地方，比如奥克兰市中心。但圣巴巴拉的美简直到了“愚蠢”的地步。没错，这里就像是一幅滑稽而如画的加州风景。几个月前，我们派制片人埃米特·菲茨杰拉德去圣巴巴拉执行一项非常繁重的报道任务。我们有这么多美丽的帆船，有鹈鹕，你刚才看到了两只海豚，太阳开始落山了。这日子真难熬。哦，海浪来了。
That was close. And it really put himself in harm's way for this story. But if you look out at the ocean from this scenic spot, you'll see something else. Something a little less conventionally attractive. Right along the horizon line, you've got one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, big offshore oil platforms. They look like buildings out there floating in the water or giant battleships or something. Not the prettiest. You can tell why people here don't love them. Those oil platforms off Santa Barbara are at the center of a complicated debate going
好险。为了这个故事，他确实让自己身处险境。但如果你从这个风景优美的地点望向大海，你会看到别的东西。一些不那么传统意义上吸引人的东西。就在地平线上，有八座巨大的海上石油平台。它们看起来就像漂浮在水面上的建筑物，或者巨大的战舰之类的东西。不太美观。你可以看出为什么这里的人不喜欢它们。圣巴巴拉外海的这些石油平台正处于一场复杂辩论的中心，
on right now within the environmental community about the relationship between nature and human infrastructure. Although, they have been a source of controversy since they first went in the water back in the 1950s and 60s. I came to Santa Barbara in 1966. This is Rodric Nash, an environmental historian who moved to Santa Barbara from New Hampshire to take a job in the history department at UCSB.
这场辩论目前正在环保界进行，关于自然与人类基础设施之间的关系。尽管自20世纪50年代和60年代它们首次投入使用以来，它们一直是争议的来源。我于1966年来到圣巴巴拉。这是罗德里克·纳什，一位环境历史学家，他从新罕布什尔州搬到圣巴巴拉，在加州大学圣巴巴拉分校历史系任职。
And it didn't take him long to fall in love with his new home. I began to realize what people had told me. They said, Santa Barbara's like the American Riviera. It's kind of a paradise. It's a land of endless summer. But at the time he says there was a sense that this coastal paradise and its lucrative tourist economy was under threat from these massive oil rigs
他没过多久就爱上了这个新家。我开始意识到人们告诉我的话。他们说，圣巴巴拉就像美国的里维埃拉。它是一个天堂。这是一片永恒的夏天之地。但当时他说，人们有一种感觉，这个沿海天堂及其利润丰厚的旅游经济正受到这些大规模石油钻井平台的威胁，
going up all throughout the Santa Barbara Channel. There were cries from the people of Santa Barbara saying, not so fast, let's think about the consequences of this. We look out at the channel. This is the million dollar view. This is what the economy and the culture of Santa Barbara is about. And now suddenly we're putting all shore oil rates out there. And we're not so sure that we're protected from spills.
这些平台正在整个圣巴巴拉海峡兴起。圣巴巴拉的人们发出呼声说，别那么快，让我们考虑一下后果。我们望向海峡。这是价值百万美元的景观。这就是圣巴巴拉的经济和文化所在。而现在，我们突然要把海上石油钻井平台放在那里。我们不太确定我们是否能免受泄漏的影响。
But at the time, there wasn't a whole lot anyone could do. The EPA didn't exist yet. There were no major environmental regulations in place, and so the oil platforms went in. And they operated without any major spills until January 28, 1969. I was working on the fourth floor of the old Paseo building that overlooked the ocean.
但在当时，没人能做什么。环保局还没成立。当时没有任何重大的环境法规，所以石油平台就建成了。它们在1969年1月28日之前一直运行，没有发生任何重大泄漏。我当时在俯瞰大海的旧帕塞奥大楼四楼工作。
This is Bud Bottoms, a local artist who actually passed away last year. This audio is from a video interview that Bottoms did a few years back where he described getting a phone call from a friend who had flown into Santa Barbara earlier that day. He was flying over the channel this particular day and he saw a big blow out. He said there's oil kind of from underneath this platform. Like crazy. The whole ocean out here is black and it's boiling up. Union Oil, the owner of the platforming question, had failed to build a large enough protective casing for one of its wells. And the oil, which was under immense pressure, forced its way around
这是巴德·博顿斯，一位去年去世的当地艺术家。这段音频来自博顿斯几年前接受的一次视频采访，他描述了接到一位当天早些时候飞抵圣巴巴拉的朋友的电话。那天他正飞越海峡，看到了一次大喷发。他说，石油正从这个平台下方涌出。太疯狂了。外面的整个海洋都是黑色的，正在沸腾。该平台的拥有者联合石油公司未能为其一口油井建造足够大的保护套管。而处于巨大压力下的石油，强行绕过
the well and erupted through the ocean floor. 1,000 gallons of crude were pouring into the ocean every hour. Roderick Nash heard about the spill that same day, but he says it took a little while for the scale of the disaster to really set in. I can remember walking down to the beach, no change, no change, and then I walked down to the beach one day and it was a black tide, There was oil and suddenly the postcard beaches of Santa Barbara were black. Crude oil floats on top of water and so the spill was particularly deadly for sea birds that dive into the water to catch fish. If you go in and your feathers are covered with oil and you can't fly, then you flap, flap helplessly on the beach.
油井，从海底喷涌而出。每小时有1000加仑的原油涌入海洋。罗德里克·纳什当天就听说了泄漏事件，但他表示，灾难的规模花了点时间才真正显现出来。我记得我走到海滩上，没什么变化，没什么变化，然后有一天我走到海滩上，那是黑色的潮汐，到处都是石油，突然间，圣巴巴拉明信片般的海滩变成了黑色。原油漂浮在水面上，因此这次泄漏对潜入水中捕鱼的海鸟来说尤其致命。如果你进去，羽毛被油覆盖，你就飞不起来了，然后你只能在海滩上无助地拍打着翅膀。
It was an apocalyptic scene, although Nash says the most uncanny thing may have been the sound. The waves were very quiet, because they were oiled. They had sort of a mushy sound, because what was really breaking was two, three inches of oil on top of the water. We stood there and cried. I hear grown men and women sitting there crying because the beach was half their life. And we thought it was all over for us. But as sad as the 1969 spill was, but bottoms was mostly just furious. I got so angry. I just screamed out. We got to get oil out. was mostly just furious.
那是一个末日般的场景，尽管纳什说最离奇的可能是声音。海浪非常安静，因为它们被油覆盖了。它们有一种糊状的声音，因为真正破碎的是水面上两三英寸厚的油。我们站在那里哭泣。我听到成年男女坐在那里哭泣，因为海滩是他们生活的一半。我们以为我们的一切都完了。但尽管1969年的泄漏令人悲伤，巴德·博顿斯主要是感到愤怒。我太生气了。我只是尖叫着。我们必须把石油弄出去。
He recalls screaming get oil out at work. And so goo, spelled GOO exclamation point, became the name of a new environmental organization that bottoms helped launch in Santa Barbara. And Goosegoal was simple. Stop all drilling and eventually get those platforms out of there. We said, well, why can't we do? You know, it's a stop the oil drilling and our beautiful pristine ocean town, Santa Barbara. Goo held rallies and marches.
他回忆起在工作中尖叫着“把石油弄出去”。于是“GOO”（石油的拼写，感叹号）成为了博顿斯在圣巴巴拉帮助发起的一个新环保组织的名字。GOO的目标很简单。停止所有钻探，最终把那些平台从那里弄走。我们说，好吧，为什么我们不能做呢？你知道，这是为了停止在我们美丽的原始海洋小镇圣巴巴拉的石油钻探。GOO举行了集会和游行。
They organized a human blockade to prevent oil trucks from reaching the harbor, and there were more creative forms of protest. We would send out bottles of little bottles of oil that was collected out of our harbor to the every, every government official there was. This thing is safe for themselves what we were dealing with. The oil spill quickly became an international news story.
他们组织了人墙封锁，以阻止油罐车到达港口，还有更具创意的抗议形式。我们会把从我们港口收集的一小瓶一小瓶的石油寄给每一位政府官员。这东西对他们自己来说是安全的，我们正在处理的是什么。石油泄漏很快成为国际新闻。
In part because of the timing, this was the very beginning of the modern environmental movement. Rachel Carson's landmark book, Silent Spring, had come out just a few years before. The Apollo 8 spacecraft was orbiting the moon for the first time, sending back photos of the Earth, looking like a blue, green marble in the empty desert of space.
部分原因是时机，这正是现代环保运动的开端。蕾切尔·卡森的里程碑式著作《寂静的春天》在几年前刚刚出版。阿波罗8号飞船首次绕月飞行，传回了地球的照片，看起来就像太空荒漠中一颗蓝绿色的弹珠。
For the first time, people were beginning to understand that the planet was small and fragile, and that humans were doing a great deal of damage. And so all those images of oil drenched seabirds dying on beautiful California beaches… They went around the world. People looked at these birds and they thought this is Santa Barbara. The spill was a galvanizing event for environmentalists. On the first anniversary, activists rallied in Santa Barbara, and some of them went on to organize
人们第一次开始明白，地球是渺小而脆弱的，人类正在造成巨大的破坏。所以所有那些被油浸透的海鸟在美丽的加州海滩上死去的照片……它们传遍了世界。人们看着这些鸟，心想这就是圣巴巴拉。这次泄漏对环保主义者来说是一个激励事件。在周年纪念日，活动人士在圣巴巴拉集会，其中一些人继续组织了
the first Earth Day. Saying, this is why we need it. This is why we need an Earth Day because of something like the Santa Barbara oil spill. The oil spill inspired Roderick Nash to start one of the country's first environmental studies programs at UC Santa Barbara. It also fueled debates in Congress and helped rally support for some of the most important environmental bills in US history. The 1969 National Environmental Policy Act was followed by the Clean Air Act in 1970, the Clean Water Act in 1972, and the Endangered Species Act in 1973, just to name a few.
第一个地球日。说，这就是为什么我们需要它。这就是为什么我们需要地球日，因为像圣巴巴拉石油泄漏这样的事情。石油泄漏激励罗德里克·纳什在加州大学圣巴巴拉分校创办了全国首批环境研究项目之一。它还助长了国会的辩论，并帮助为美国历史上一些最重要的环境法案争取了支持。1969年的《国家环境政策法》之后，1970年通过了《清洁空气法》，1972年通过了《清洁水法》，1973年通过了《濒危物种法》，仅举几例。
Increasingly as you look back at it, from now, 50 years, and you look back at it, you can really say, holy cow, there was a lot of change. And the Santa Barbara oil spill had a lot to do with that change. The spill catalyzed a national movement, but there was still the question of the platforms themselves. Local opposition put a stop to most new oil exploration of California, but the existing oil rigs have continued to operate for decades. Today, many of those old platforms are reaching the end of their productive lifetimes, and
当你从现在回望这50年，你真的可以说，天哪，变化太大了。圣巴巴拉石油泄漏与这种变化有很大关系。这次泄漏催化了一场全国性的运动，但关于平台本身的问题依然存在。当地的反对声阻止了加州大部分新的石油勘探，但现有的石油钻井平台几十年来一直在运行。今天，许多旧平台正接近其生产寿命的终点，并且
based on their original lease agreements, they should be decommissioned and removed from the water. Carla Frisk is on the board of goo. It's still around. And she can't wait for the oil companies to be gone. Get to the end of your lease and be done. And then get your equipment and go away. Get oil out if you will.
根据最初的租赁协议，它们应该被退役并从水中移除。卡拉·弗里斯克是GOO的董事会成员。它依然存在。她迫不及待地想让石油公司离开。租约到期就结束吧。然后带上你的设备走人。如果可以的话，把石油弄出去。
Yeah, the name still says it all really. Yeah, you don't have any doubts about what the organization is about, right off the bat. Frisk wants the oil companies to return the Santa Barbara channel to the way it was before the platforms went in the water. A pristine ocean environment without any giant artificial structures. And when you go down there, you know, that you would never know that they were there. I mean, that's really what it should be. You know, when you have come to the ocean, it should be the ocean.
是的，这个名字确实说明了一切。是的，你对这个组织是做什么的没有任何怀疑，一目了然。弗里斯克希望石油公司将圣巴巴拉海峡恢复到平台进入水域之前的样子。一个没有任何巨大人工结构的原始海洋环境。当你去那里时，你知道，你永远不会知道它们曾经在那里。我的意思是，这才是它应该有的样子。你知道，当你来到大海时，它就应该是大海。
That simple goal, the one that members of Gooh have been fighting for since the 1960s, it would seem like it's time has finally come. But there's one little hitch. These platforms are the most productive habitats in the world ocean, habitats in the world ocean. Anywhere in the world. This is Milton Love.
那个简单的目标，GOO成员自20世纪60年代以来一直为之奋斗的目标，似乎终于到了实现的时候了。但有一个小障碍。这些平台是世界海洋中最具生产力的栖息地，世界海洋中的栖息地。世界上任何地方。这是米尔顿·洛夫。
I'm a research biologist at the Marine Science Institute, University of California, Santa Barbara. Love is author of classic science books, like, and this is really the title, probably more than you want to know about the fishes of the Pacific Coast and also the sequel. Certainly more than you want to know about the fishes of the Pacific Coast, a post-modern experience. It's a 650-page home full of fish-faxist, historical anecdotes and some of his original poetry.
我是加州大学圣巴巴拉分校海洋科学研究所的研究生物学家。洛夫是经典科学书籍的作者，比如——这真的是书名——《关于太平洋沿岸鱼类，你可能想知道的更多》，以及续集《当然，关于太平洋沿岸鱼类，你可能想知道的更多：一种后现代体验》。这是一本650页的巨著，充满了鱼类事实、历史轶事和他的一些原创诗歌。
According to Love, it weighs 5.4 pounds. It's actually a dangerous weapon in the wrong hands. And it feels cliche to say that a scientist just really loves the thing that they study, but it must be said. Milton Love's Fish. I have two tattoos of fish, and one is of a cow-cod, which is a rock fish. But the other one is of a deep water angler fish. Is it in a decent place? Can I see it? Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
据洛夫说，它重5.4磅。在错误的人手中，它实际上是一种危险的武器。说科学家真的热爱他们研究的东西听起来很陈词滥调，但必须得说。米尔顿·洛夫的鱼。我有两个鱼的纹身，一个是牛鳕，那是一种岩鱼。但另一个是深海鮟鱇鱼。它在合适的地方吗？我能看看吗？哦，是的，是的，是的。
Well, hold on a sec. I have to take my shirt off. Without thinking twice, he pulls off his shirt to reveal a fading shoulder tattoo. It's this big female angler fish with a tiny little male fish latched onto her side. So there is the female and that little nubby thing that's the male there. Love grew up fishing on the beaches and piers of Santa Monica. He studied biology at UCSB and
好吧，等一下。我得脱掉衬衫。他毫不犹豫地脱下衬衫，露出肩膀上一个正在褪色的纹身。那是一条巨大的雌性鮟鱇鱼，旁边附着一条小小的雄性鱼。所以那是雌性，那个小小的凸起物就是雄性。洛夫是在圣莫尼卡的沙滩和码头上钓鱼长大的。他在加州大学圣巴巴拉分校学习生物学，并且
eventually ended up back at his alma mater where he started up his own research lab, the Love Lab. But in the lab's early days, he had a really hard time getting grants to fund his fish research. And, uh, in 1995, I was at a low point. There was no question. I had no funding. But just when things were at their bleakest, Love got an unexpected phone call. I answer the phone. He says, this is Lyman Thorstonson. I'm from the National Biological Survey, which was a government program in the 90s
最终回到了他的母校，在那里他创办了自己的研究实验室——洛夫实验室。但在实验室成立初期，他很难获得资助来支持他的鱼类研究。而且，呃，1995年，我处于低谷。毫无疑问。我没有资金。但就在情况最黯淡的时候，洛夫接到了一个意想不到的电话。我接了电话。他说，我是莱曼·索斯顿森。我来自国家生物调查局，这是90年代的一个政府项目，
that aimed to catalog and describe ecosystems throughout the country. And I swear to God, this is what he said. He said, if you had money for research, what would you do? Which is not how science usually works. Nobody. Nobody calls and says I have money. It's the other way around. It's a very Dickensian kind of thing. It's like you're the little beggar boy. You come over and you go like,
旨在编目和描述全国各地的生态系统。我发誓，这就是他说的。他说，如果你有研究经费，你会做什么？这通常不是科学运作的方式。没有人，没有人会打电话说我有钱。情况恰恰相反。这是一种非常狄更斯式的事情。就像你是那个小乞丐。你走过去说，
please, could I have $100,000? Please. Love thought about how to answer this surprise question. And he landed on something that had been nagging him since he first came to Santa Barbara. Back in his 20s, love used to collect fish for a local aquarium, and one day he and his fishing partner took their little Boston whaler out to the oil platforms and started fishing around them.
拜托，能给我10万美元吗？拜托。洛夫思考着如何回答这个突如其来的问题。他想到了一个自他第一次来到圣巴巴拉以来就一直困扰他的事情。20多岁时，洛夫曾为当地一家水族馆收集鱼类，有一天他和他的钓鱼伙伴开着他们的小波士顿捕鲸船去了石油平台，开始在周围钓鱼。
There was like fish up the wazoo, and we could have filled up the aquarium with all the fish we caught. Ever since then he had wondered what was going on down there. And so here's this dude like offering me money and I said well I'm really interested in these oil platforms off here. They're large structures I'd like to know the role that they play as habitat for fishes and he said oh that sounds interesting. And so, funding in hand, Milton Love got a team together, rented a small submarine, and began to study the platforms. The first dive I made in the submersible was a platform
那里鱼多得不得了，我们可以用我们捕到的所有鱼填满水族馆。从那时起，他就一直想知道下面发生了什么。所以这个家伙给我钱，我说，嗯，我对这里的这些石油平台真的很感兴趣。它们是大型结构，我想知道它们作为鱼类栖息地所扮演的角色，他说，哦，那听起来很有趣。于是，在资金到位的情况下，米尔顿·洛夫组建了一个团队，租了一艘小型潜水艇，开始研究这些平台。我在潜水器中进行的第一次潜水是一个平台，
of Hidalgo, which is located just barely into central California. It sits in about 450 feet of water. He took the submersible all the way to the bottom, where the pylons reached the sea bed. I was like blown away. I didn't actually know what to expect, and there was a lot of fish. In particular, schools of adult rock fish were swirling around the base of the platform. And as he started making his way up the structure, he saw a lot of smaller juvenile fish.
伊达尔戈号，它位于加州中部边缘。它坐落在约450英尺深的水中。他把潜水器一直开到海底，那里塔架触及海床。我当时惊呆了。我实际上不知道会发生什么，那里有很多鱼。特别是，成群的成年岩鱼在平台底部盘旋。当他开始沿着结构向上移动时，他看到了许多较小的幼鱼。
And we're talking hundreds of thousands of these young fish. Then the metal itself was covered with colorful invertebrates, sea stars, muscles, sponges, and these little crabs walking all over the struts. I remember coming back on deck to the research vessel and the hatch pops and everybody's, you know, all the lab is there and the crew of the boats there and they're waiting for me to say something and I said, yeah, this was like, I said, this is like an amazing place. That platform dive was the first of many that Milton Love and the other scientists at
我们说的是成千上万条这种幼鱼。然后金属本身覆盖着色彩斑斓的无脊椎动物、海星、贻贝、海绵，还有这些小螃蟹在支柱上走来走去。我记得回到研究船的甲板上，舱口打开，每个人，你知道，整个实验室的人都在那里，船员也在那里，他们等着我说点什么，我说，是的，这就像，我说，这就像一个神奇的地方。那次平台潜水是米尔顿·洛夫和其他科学家在
the Love Lab would do over the next 15 years. Love remembers one dive in particular from this period, around a platform called Gilda. One of his colleagues went down first, and when she came back up, she said, basically, that was unbelievable. The scientist always videotaped these dives to show people who didn't believe them, and so she played them the recording right there on the boat. She put it in there and we're going like, oh my god, that's the most fish we've ever seen around a platform. Not every trip down was like that.
洛夫实验室在接下来的15年里进行的众多潜水中的第一次。洛夫记得这一时期的一次特别潜水，是在一个叫吉尔达的平台周围。他的一位同事先下去了，当她上来时，她说，基本上，那简直令人难以置信。科学家总是把这些潜水过程录像，以展示给那些不相信他们的人看，所以她就在船上播放了录像。她把它放进去，我们看着说，天哪，那是我们在平台周围见过的最多的鱼。并非每次下潜都是那样的。
All platforms are different, love says. Some don't have a lot of fish, and it always varies year to year. But often love found that these oil platforms were like little oasis of marine life. The ocean is a big, empty place, and animals tend to concentrate around stuff. The only reason they're there is they like to hang out with stuff. Many invertebrates need a physical object to latch onto, and rockfish want to hide in nooks and crannies, or just be around anything with a little structure to it. They don't care what the structure is made out of, it can be a pipe, it can be a platform,
洛夫说，所有平台都不一样。有些没有多少鱼，而且每年都在变化。但洛夫经常发现，这些石油平台就像海洋生物的小绿洲。海洋是一个巨大、空旷的地方，动物倾向于聚集在物体周围。它们在那里唯一的理由是它们喜欢和东西待在一起。许多无脊椎动物需要一个物理物体来附着，而岩鱼想躲在角落和缝隙里，或者只是待在任何有一点结构的东西周围。它们不在乎结构是用什么做的，它可以是一根管子，可以是一个平台，
it can be a tire, it can be a rock. Oil platforms are particularly popular structures with the fishes because they have a lot of surface area and complexity, and they extend hundreds of feet through the water column like a marine skyscraper. Rockfish live at different depths throughout their life cycle, making the oil platform this incredible home for fish of all ages. Younger fish tend to live higher up the platform, and time after time love was finding lots of them. There were so many that I started thinking like, what does this mean biologically?
它可以是一个轮胎，可以是一块岩石。石油平台是鱼类特别受欢迎的结构，因为它们有很大的表面积和复杂性，并且像海洋摩天大楼一样在水柱中延伸数百英尺。岩鱼在生命周期的不同深度生活，使石油平台成为所有年龄段鱼类的绝佳家园。较小的鱼倾向于生活在平台较高的地方，洛夫一次又一次地发现了很多。数量之多，以至于我开始想，这在生物学上意味着什么？
Like, okay, so we're seeing a lot of juvenile fish, but how important are these platforms really in terms of the overall ecosystem? To try and get to the bottom of that, love and his team looked at one particular species of rockfish, the Bacaccio. Yeah, it's got a big mouth. That's what it means in Italian. Bacaccio means big mouth. The Bacaccio are heavily fished around Santa Barbara, and around this time the stock was so depleted that the government closed the fishery. But when love did a survey of seven different oil platforms, there's all these baby Bacaccio, and I mean we're talking a lot of them. About 450,000.
比如，好吧，我们看到了很多幼鱼，但这些平台在整个生态系统方面到底有多重要？为了弄清这一点，洛夫和他的团队研究了一种特定的岩鱼，即大口鲉。是的，它有一张大嘴。在意大利语中就是这个意思。大口鲉意味着大嘴。大口鲉在圣巴巴拉周围被大量捕捞，大约在这个时候，种群数量减少得如此严重，以至于政府关闭了渔场。但当洛夫对七个不同的石油平台进行调查时，到处都是小大口鲉，我的意思是，我们说的是很多。大约45万条。
To put that number in context, love called up a scientist at the National Marine Fisheries Service, who was responsible for counting all the Baccaccio on the Pacific coast. His name was Alex. So I said, Alex, we estimated that there were 450,000 baby Baccaccio at these seven platforms. Is that important? Because maybe it's not. I didn't know. So he had a model that he used. So he plugged that in and he came back a couple weeks later and he said, well, on an average year, that's 20%. Of all the baby bubukaccio on the entire Pacific coast, we're at those seven platforms. And babies are particularly important to rebuilding the overall population. So I'm going like, you know what? That seems like those platforms were important
为了把这个数字放在背景中，洛夫给国家海洋渔业局的一位科学家打了电话，他负责统计太平洋沿岸所有的所有大口鲉。他的名字叫亚历克斯。所以我说，亚历克斯，我们估计在这七个平台上有45万条幼年大口鲉。这重要吗？因为也许并不重要。我不知道。所以他有一个他使用的模型。所以他输入了这个数字，几周后他回来告诉我，嗯，在平均年份，那是20%。整个太平洋沿岸所有幼年大口鲉的20%都在那七个平台上。而幼鱼对于重建整体种群尤为重要。所以我说，你知道吗？这看起来那些平台对于重建那个特定物种很重要。
for rebuilding that particular species. Still, as love's results were coming in, a lot of people were skeptical. Like, maybe the rigs were just luring fish away from natural habitats. Love says that's a totally valid concern and it does happen with a lot of artificial reefs. But after years of studying these oil platforms, he feels confident that at least for some species of fish, the platforms are giving the overall population a boost. The preponderance of evidence is that for eight or ten or maybe twelve species of rockfish, there are more of them in California because of all these platforms
尽管如此，随着洛夫的研究结果出炉，很多人持怀疑态度。比如，也许这些钻井平台只是把鱼从自然栖息地引诱走了。洛夫说这是一个完全合理的担忧，这在许多人工鱼礁中确实会发生。但在研究了这些石油平台多年后，他确信，至少对于某些鱼类来说，这些平台正在给整体种群带来提升。证据的优势在于，对于八、十或十二种岩鱼来说，因为所有这些平台，加州的数量比没有这些平台时要多。
than would be here if the platforms were not here. And some scientists would go even further. A few years ago, someone else tried to calculate just how biologically productive the platforms were. The most productive habitats are places like rainforests, coral reefs, but when the scientists ran the numbers, he found that these platforms are the most productive habitats in the world ocean, anywhere in the world. Now, we should take that with the grain of salt
而且一些科学家会走得更远。几年前，有人试图计算这些平台在生物学上到底有多高产。最高产的栖息地是雨林、珊瑚礁之类的地方，但当科学家计算这些数字时，他发现这些平台是世界海洋中最高产的栖息地，世界上任何地方。现在，我们应该对这个结论持保留态度，
there are tons of habitats that scientists haven't studied in this way. But the point is... These are fully functioning reefs. They contain all the animals that you would expect to see on a myriad of natural reefs, which begs the question, is it in the interests of the people of California to blow up a fully functioning reef and destroy it. In 2010, the California legislature decided it wasn't and they passed AB 2503,
有无数的栖息地科学家还没有以这种方式研究过。但重点是……这些是功能齐全的礁石。它们包含了你期望在无数自然礁石上看到的所有动物，这就引出了一个问题，炸毁一个功能齐全的礁石并摧毁它，是否符合加州人民的利益。2010年，加州立法机构决定不符合，他们通过了AB 2503，
a bill known as Riggs to Reefs, which allow the oil companies to leave an oil platform in place if it could be shown to have a net benefit on the marine environment. The oil companies would still need to plug the wells and lop off the top of the platforms that boats could travel over it, but they would be allowed to leave some of the structure in place. So far, though, no one has made use of this bill, and the future of California's offshore platforms is still very much up in the air. And a lot of environmentalists aren't sold on the idea of turning rigs into reefs.
一项被称为“钻井平台变礁石”的法案，允许石油公司在证明对海洋环境有净收益的情况下，将石油平台留在原地。石油公司仍然需要封堵油井并切掉平台顶部，以便船只可以从上面通过，但他们将被允许保留部分结构。然而到目前为止，还没有人利用这项法案，加州海上平台的未来仍然悬而未决。而且许多环保主义者并不买账将钻井平台变成礁石的想法。
They have concerns about liability and the potential for future leaks. And the original lease agreement specified that the platforms would be fully removed when the oil ran out. There wasn't a loophole that said they could stay if they turned into beautiful fish habitat. To me it's breaking a promise. This is Carla Frisk again from Go. The promise was, these would go away and now they don't want them to go away. To tell a community, don't worry, we're going to clean up our garbage after we're gone.
他们担心责任和未来泄漏的可能性。最初的租赁协议规定，当石油耗尽时，平台将被完全拆除。并没有一个漏洞说如果它们变成了美丽的鱼类栖息地就可以留下来。对我来说，这是违背承诺。这是GOO的卡拉·弗里斯克。承诺是，这些东西会消失，现在他们不想让它们消失。告诉社区，别担心，我们走后会清理我们的垃圾。
And then it's like, well, we're going to mean that. And even if you love fish and I really do love fish. Her frustration is understandable. Environmental activists in Santa Barbara have had to deal with oil in their backyard for the last 50 years. In 2015, an oil pipeline, a few miles north of Santa Barbara, started leaking right into the ocean. It was a horrible reminder of the 69th spill, and the dangers of living with oil infrastructure. And now, the oil companies are saying, hey, these giant structures in the ocean that cause you all these problems? No, they're actually good for the environment.
然后就像是，嗯，我们要食言了。即使你热爱鱼类，我也确实热爱鱼类。她的沮丧是可以理解的。圣巴巴拉的环保活动人士在过去50年里不得不处理后院的石油问题。2015年，圣巴巴拉以北几英里处的一条输油管道开始直接向海洋泄漏。这令人痛苦地想起了69年的泄漏事件，以及与石油基础设施共存的危险。而现在，石油公司却说，嘿，这些导致你们所有问题的海洋巨型结构？不，它们实际上对环境有好处。
Look at the research, they're habitat. It's not about habitat. Carla is not convinced that oil executives support rigs to reefs because of their concern for the rockfish. My feeling is that they're motivated by saving money. I can't save a whole lot of money by not pulling those out. The rigs off Santa Barbara
看看研究，它们是栖息地。这与栖息地无关。卡拉不相信石油高管支持“钻井平台变礁石”是因为他们关心岩鱼。我的感觉是，他们是为了省钱。我不拆除那些东西可以省下一大笔钱。圣巴巴拉外海的钻井平台
are massive pieces of infrastructure, some of the largest oil platforms in the world. Fully removing them would be extremely difficult and avoiding those costs could save the oil companies millions of dollars. Under the 2010 rigs to Reef's Bill, those savings would be split with a state, but still, a lot of environmental groups don't love signing off on a policy
是巨大的基础设施，是世界上一些最大的石油平台。完全拆除它们将极其困难，避免这些成本可以为石油公司节省数百万美元。根据2010年的“钻井平台变礁石”法案，这些节省的资金将与州政府平分，但即便如此，许多环保组织并不喜欢签署一项政策，
that feels like a handout to the oil industry. Especially because environmental groups are currently fighting new offshore oil development. The Trump administration has indicated that they want to issue new offshore oil and gas leases off California. California has resisted the plan, but environmental groups worry that if the costs of decommissioning go down and the oil companies can argue that these structures are actually good for wildlife, they could have an easier time building new oil platforms. And new offshore oil drilling is the worst case scenario that all environmental groups want to avoid, not just because of the risk of future spills,
这感觉像是给石油行业的施舍。特别是因为环保组织目前正在反对新的海上石油开发。特朗普政府已表示希望在加州外海发放新的海上油气租约。加州抵制了该计划，但环保组织担心，如果退役成本降低，石油公司可以辩称这些结构实际上对野生动物有益，他们可能更容易建造新的石油平台。而新的海上石油钻探是所有环保组织想要避免的最坏情况，不仅因为未来泄漏的风险，
but because if we want to stop the worst impacts of climate change, we're going to have to start leaving fossil fuels in the ground. Milton Love agrees that climate change is one of the biggest threats to the world's oceans. And so I asked him what he thinks about the fact that the oil industry probably likes his research? I have tended to avoid dealing with the oil industry to the extent I can, but obviously they read my my papers. You know, they like it. I guess. I mean, I've never had a CEO call me up and go like, this is great stuff, man. I loved your stuff and thank you thank you thank I'm never anybody do that. But his findings have definitely helped oil companies make their argument. To the extent that my findings bolster the oil companies
而且因为如果我们想阻止气候变化的最坏影响，我们将不得不开始把化石燃料留在地下。米尔顿·洛夫同意气候变化是世界海洋面临的最大威胁之一。所以我问他，对于石油行业可能喜欢他的研究这一事实，他怎么看？我倾向于尽可能避免与石油行业打交道，但显然他们读了我的论文。你知道，他们喜欢它。我想。我的意思是，我从来没有接到过CEO的电话说，这东西太棒了，伙计。我喜欢你的东西，谢谢谢谢，我从来没有遇到过任何人这样做。但他的发现确实帮助石油公司提出了他们的论点。在我的发现支持石油公司立场的情况下，
positions that's just what happens with facts. The facts of Milton Love's research don't mean that oil infrastructure is good for wildlife that usually isn't. They just mean that in a few instances off the Southern California coast, oil platforms have become useful habitat for a few different species of fish. Love is not in favor of building new offshore oil platforms, or even building lots of new artificial reefs. But in this situation, the artificial reef is already there. My view is once you put something in the ocean,
这就是事实会发生的情况。米尔顿·洛夫的研究事实并不意味着石油基础设施对野生动物有益，通常情况并非如此。它们只是意味着在南加州海岸外的少数情况下，石油平台已经成为少数几种鱼类的有用栖息地。洛夫并不赞成建造新的海上石油平台，甚至不赞成建造大量新的人工鱼礁。但在这种情况下，人工鱼礁已经存在了。我的观点是，一旦你把东西放进海洋，
and it becomes habitat for animals, I don't think you should pull it out, because like, why should we punish those animals? Just because they have the misfortune of settling out on a piece of steel rather than on a rock. After all, rockfish are just looking for a little structure in their lives. They don't care if it's a rocky outcrop or a shipwreck or an oil platform. Special thanks to Kristen Hyslop of the Environmental Defense Center who also spoke to us for this story, and also a big thank you to Janet Bridgers from Earth Alert for kindly letting us use audio from her interview with Bud Bottoms. Coming up, taking what we learned from offshore oil platforms and applying it to offshore wind
它就成了动物的栖息地，我不认为你应该把它拆除，因为，为什么我们要惩罚那些动物？仅仅因为它们不幸地定居在一块钢材上而不是岩石上。毕竟，岩鱼只是在寻找生活中的一点结构。它们不在乎是岩石露头、沉船还是石油平台。特别感谢环境防御中心的克里斯汀·海斯洛普，她也为这个故事接受了我们的采访，也非常感谢地球警报的珍妮特·布里奇斯，感谢她好心地让我们使用她采访巴德·博顿斯的音频。接下来，将我们从海上石油平台学到的东西应用到海上风电
farms. After this. So one of the things about doing a story like this, where we talk about the accidental benefits of humans putting stuff in the ocean, is that you could possibly come away with the idea that this is necessarily a good thing all the time, and we should just dump stuff in the ocean. And so I'm in the studio here with Emmett Fitzgerald who reported that piece to address this issue head on.
场。广告后见。所以，做这样一个故事，谈论人类把东西放进海洋的意外好处，其中一点就是你可能会得出这样的想法：这在任何时候都是一件好事，我们应该把东西扔进海洋。所以我现在和报道那篇报道的埃米特·菲茨杰拉德在演播室里，直接解决这个问题。
Yeah, I know it was something I was a little nervous about with the piece. You could kind of draw the wrong conclusion, conclusion or take the conclusion of the piece too far. If you start to think fish together around stuff, then let's just... What a bunch of stuff in. Into the water. The crazy thing is that we have done this. We have built artificial reefs a lot in the past. And people have thrown all kinds of things into the ocean thinking that this was going to be beneficial.
是的，我知道这是我对比这篇报道感到有点紧张的事情。你可能会得出错误的结论，或者把报道的结论推得太远。如果你开始认为鱼聚集在东西周围，那么让我们把一堆东西扔进水里吧。疯狂的是，我们确实做过这种事。我们过去建造了很多人工鱼礁。人们把各种各样的东西扔进海洋，认为这会有益。
There's been old washing machines or subway cars. They even sunk an old aircraft carrier ones off the floor to Panhandle. It became known as the great carrier reef. That's clever. And the results are mixed often when you put structure into the water, it does attract fish. And as a result, actually, one of the constituencies of the people that have tended to support
有旧洗衣机或地铁车厢。他们甚至在佛罗里达狭长地带外海沉没了一艘旧航空母舰。它被称为“大航母礁”。这很聪明。结果喜忧参半，通常当你把结构放入水中时，它确实会吸引鱼类。因此，实际上，倾向于支持这些项目的选民之一，人工鱼礁的支持者是渔民，因为这把所有的鱼集中在一个地方，使它们更容易捕获。因此，反对人工鱼礁的一个论点是，它们导致或可能加剧过度捕捞。这绝对是一个真正的担忧。而且，你知道，我的意思是，我遇到的一个更令人震惊的误导性人工鱼礁尝试的例子，发生在20世纪70年代，当时人们把50万个轮胎，汽车轮胎扔进了劳德代尔堡外海的海洋中，表面上是为了创造一个人造礁石。这看起来是建造礁石最糟糕的基质，
these sorts of projects, artificial reefing are fishermen because it concentrates all the fish in one place and makes them easier to catch. And so an argument against artificial reefs is that they lead to or can exacerbate overfishing. And that's totally a real concern. And there's also, you know, I mean, one of the more egregious examples of a misguided artificial reefing attempt that I came across, you know, happened in the 1970s, where people dumped half a million tires, automobile tires into the ocean off Fort Lauderdale, ostensibly, you know, in an effort to create an artificial reef. That seems like the worst possible substrate
根本不适合生命生存。完全是这样，而且是一个彻底的失败。现在那里周围是一个30英亩的死区，不仅如此，轮胎还浸出了对天然珊瑚礁有害的物质，鱼类也没有回来。你知道，这算是把这个想法推向极端的某种最坏情况。所以教训是，我们不应该只是用我们的东西填满海洋。
to build a reef upon. Yeah, like it's like not conducing to life at all. Completely, and it was an abject failure. It's like a 30, it's like a 30 acre dead zone around there now, and not only that, but like the tires leached stuff that was detrimental to a natural coral reef Right and fish haven't come back. You know, it's sort of the worst case scenario of taking this idea and going too far with it So the lesson is we should not just fill the ocean with our stuff
绝对不要，不要从这个故事中得出那个教训。但我们确实会把人类基础设施放入海洋。作为人类，我们会把东西放在海洋环境中。我们正在港口周围建造防波堤。我们正在建造桥梁。我们正在建造，我们一直在建造大量的石油平台。展望未来，我们可能会建造大量的可再生能源，你知道，海上风电的风力平台。所以，这是杰里米·克拉斯。他是加州理工波莫纳分校的海洋生物学教授。
Absolutely not do not take that lesson away from the story But we are going to put human infrastructure into the ocean. As humans, we're going to put things out in the marine environment. We're building break waters around harbours. We're building bridges. We're building, we have been building a lot of oil platforms. Moving the future, we're probably going to be building a lot of renewable energy, you know, wind platform for offshore wind. So, this is Jeremy Klase. He's a professor of marine biology at Cal Poly Pomona.
他实际上就是那个计算并量化了加州石油钻井平台生物生产力的科学家，如果你还记得故事里的那个内容的话。杰里米的论点基本上是，你知道，有了所有这些基础设施，我们应该考虑它对海洋环境的影响，看看是否可以在结构进入水域之前进行设计，这样它就有机会成为有益的栖息地。所以在石油平台的故事中，这些结构成为礁石完全是一个意外，但他是在说，也许我们可以有意地做一些这样的事情，或者甚至通过一些意图做得更好。没错。如果我们考虑，你知道，我们如何设计人类基础设施以最大化其栖息地效益，基本上。
And he was actually the scientist that ran the numbers and quantified how biologically productive the California oil rigs are if you remember that from the story. And Jeremy's argument is basically that, you know, with all of this infrastructure, we should be thinking about the impact that it will have on the marine environment and seeing if there are ways that we could design the structure before it goes in the water so that it, you know, has a chance to become beneficial habitat. So in the oil platform story, it was a total accident that these structures became reefs, but he's saying that maybe we can actually do some of this intentionally or maybe even do it better with some intention. Right. If we think about, you know, how we could design human infrastructure to maximize its habitat benefits, basically.
他特别关注海上风电的问题，对我来说，这是一个非常有趣的例子，因为与气候变化方面存在问题的石油平台不同，海上风电是一种气候解决方案，也是一种潜在的非常重要的气候解决方案。现在，我们知道在未来几十年里，我们将需要建造很多这样的结构。如果我们想避免气候变化方面的最坏情况，我们将需要一些海上风电。希望这些海上风电平台
And he's particularly focused on the question of offshore wind, which to me is this really interesting example because unlike oil platforms which are problematic when it comes to climate change, offshore wind is this climate solution and this potentially really important climate solution. Now, we know that we're going to need to build a lot of these structures in the coming decades. If we want to avoid the worst case scenarios when it comes to climate change, we're going to need some offshore wind. And hopefully, these offshore wind platforms
在设计时可以考虑到这一点。一旦它们被放置在那里，我们就可以研究它们，了解正在发生的积极和消极方面，并尝试随着时间的推移进行修正。并尽我们所能处理我们放入海洋环境中的所有这些东西。那么这在任何地方发生了吗？
thought can be put into designing them. And then once they're put out there, we can study them and understand, you know, the positive and negatives that's going on and try to revise those over time. And do the best we can with all this stuff we're putting out into the marine environment. So is this happening anywhere yet?
还是有人在积极设计以生物生命为优先的风力平台？是的，我们正处于这个阶段的开始，但目前世界上海上风电最多的地方是欧洲的北海。那里有很多风力涡轮机，它们基本上只是通过一根杆子连接到海床上。
Or is it anyone actively designing wind platforms with biological life as a priority? Yeah, we're kind of at the beginning of this, but the place right now in the world with the most offshore wind is the North Sea in Europe. And there are a lot of wind turbines there that are just, they're basically just attached to the seabed by a single
那个结构没有太多的复杂性。海上石油平台真正伟大的地方之一是它们具有一些鱼类倾向于喜欢的结构复杂性。所以在北海，人们正在做的一件事是开始思考，我们如何为这些风力涡轮机增加一点结构复杂性。在欧洲和北海，他们正在采取措施增加底部的复杂性。有机会通过采石或不同的结构来创造更复杂的栖息地，以试图改善生活在那里的鱼类的栖息地。
pole. And it doesn't have a lot of complexity that structure. And one of the things that's really great about offshore oil platforms is that they've got some of that structural complexity that fish tend to like. And so in the North Sea, one thing that people are doing is starting to think about like, how can we add a little bit of structural complexity to these wind turbines. In Europe and the North Sea, they're doing things to increase the complexity down at the base. There's opportunities to create more complex habitat surrounding it with quarry rock or different structures to try to improve the habitat for fish living down there.
但在加州外海，情况实际上非常不同。在加州，当你向海里走去时，海底下降得非常快，而且变得非常深。所以加州的海上风力涡轮机，如果它们真的出现，实际上需要设计成浮动的。因此，在部署这些浮动结构方面有一整套新的挑战，但其中许多，水下的部分，与这些海上石油平台水下的顶部部分是非常相似的结构。
But off-California, the situation is actually really different. The ocean floor, as you go out to sea on California, drops off really quickly and gets really deep. And so offshore wind turbines in California, if they do come, are actually going to need to be designed to float. So there's a whole set of new challenges in terms of deploying these floating structures, but a lot of them, the part that's going to be underwater, is very similar sorts of structure to the top part that's underwater of these offshore oil platforms.
但在加州外海，情况其实大不相同。加州的海床向外延伸时下降得非常快，变得非常深。因此，如果加州要建设海上风力涡轮机，它们实际上需要设计成浮动式的。所以，在部署这些浮动结构方面存在一系列全新的挑战，但其中很大一部分，即水下部分，与这些海上石油平台的水下部分结构非常相似。
So kind of where we're at right now is trying to study the fish living on these offshore oil platforms as kind of a proxy for what you would expect the fish are going to experience living off these floating wind platforms. So Jeremy is hoping that his research can inform the design of these structures if and when offshore wind becomes a reality in California. But you know, it was interesting talking to Jeremy. He's like, he's a marine biologist and is obviously focused on fish. There are huge engineering challenges and design challenges with offshore wind. And so like getting these people to care about fish
我们目前所处的情况是，试图研究生活在这些海上石油平台上的鱼类，以此作为一种代理指标，来推测鱼类在浮动风力发电平台周围的生活状况。因此，杰里米希望他的研究能在加州海上风电成为现实时，为这些结构的设计提供参考。但你知道，与杰里米交谈很有趣。他是一位海洋生物学家，显然专注于鱼类。海上风电面临着巨大的工程和设计挑战。所以，让这些人关心鱼类
is not necessarily, he doesn't think it's gonna necessarily be the easiest. I think the economic and engineering challenges are pretty great with these structures. So initially at least it's probably hard to come in and say, well, let's think about how these are going to be good for the fish. But ultimately, I think that's what we should be doing.
并不一定，他不认为这会是最容易的事情。我认为这些结构在经济和工程方面面临的挑战相当大。所以至少在最初，很难一上来就说，好吧，让我们考虑一下这些东西如何对鱼类有益。但归根结底，我认为这正是我们应该做的。
At the end of the day, we still, we shouldn't get too carried away with these ideas or think that we can design perfect habitats and at the expense of natural ones. I think that anytime we put a big piece of infrastructure into the water, it's going to be disruptive on some level. And that's always true. And we always need to be thinking about how to mitigate the negative impacts that a big piece of human infrastructure is going to have.
归根结底，我们仍然不应该对这些想法过于着迷，或者认为我们可以以牺牲自然栖息地为代价来设计完美的栖息地。我认为，任何时候我们在水中放置大型基础设施，都会在某种程度上造成破坏。这一点永远是事实。我们始终需要考虑如何减轻大型人类基础设施带来的负面影响。
With offshore wind, a thing that people are obviously very concerned about is seabirds. That's a whole other set of design challenges. How do you build these structures in a way where they don't disrupt seabird habitat? But I think the first step is how do we mitigate disruption and damage? And then you can start thinking about what are ways in which we could maybe actually have small benefits. Right. Design should never replace the concept of conservation. Totally.
对于海上风电，人们显然非常关心海鸟。这是另一套完全不同的设计挑战。你如何建造这些结构，使它们不破坏海鸟的栖息地？但我认为第一步是如何减轻破坏和损害。然后你就可以开始考虑我们如何才能真正带来一些小的好处。没错。设计永远不应该取代保护的概念。完全正确。
By conservation and impact design should go hand in hand. And even though we can make a nice habitat on the bottom of a wind platform, it doesn't mean that we shouldn't be protecting the natural reefs and environment just as much as we always should. You know, like, it doesn't replace it at all. Completely. There's no, there's nothing you're going to design is better than what's... And leaving nature alone. Exactly. To be good.
保护和影响设计应该齐头并进。即使我们能在风电平台底部创造一个不错的栖息地，也不意味着我们不应该像往常一样保护天然珊瑚礁和环境。你知道，它根本无法取代自然。完全不能。你设计的任何东西都不可能比……让大自然顺其自然更好。没错。那才是好的。
Right. Completely. And some of the most interesting work that's being done in terms of artificial reefs that I think people do support is, do support is thinking about habitat restoration. You know, a place where we've done a lot of damage with some other kind of development, is there a way that we can intervene again with some kind of design solution,
没错。完全正确。我认为人们支持的一些关于人工鱼礁的最有趣的工作，是关于栖息地恢复的思考。你知道，在某些地方，我们通过其他类型的开发造成了很大的破坏，有没有办法我们可以再次通过某种设计方案进行干预，
but for the purposes of trying to rehabilitate something that was already there? Right, and then maybe also have future policies in which we don't disrupt reefs to begin with. Yeah, that's, that's, yeah. That begin with. Yeah, that's the nice too. That's the ultimate goal. 99% of visible's impact design coverage is supported by Autodesk.
但目的是为了修复已经存在的东西？没错，也许还可以制定未来的政策，让我们从一开始就不去破坏珊瑚礁。是的，那是，那是，是的。从一开始。是的，那也很好。那是最终目标。《99% Invisible》的影响力设计报道由 Autodesk 支持。
The Autodesk Foundation supports the design and creation of innovative solutions to the world's most pressing social and environmental challenges, like coral reef conservation and restoration. Seacore is a non-profit global network of scientists and other interested parties that is creating ceramic seating units, some which look like little ninja throwing stars, that are covered in coral larvae and are dropped off of boats, and take hold in the nooks and crannies of damaged reefs and repopulate the ecosystem. They're using 3D printing and rapid prototyping to determine the best material and design combination
Autodesk 基金会支持设计和创造创新的解决方案，以应对世界上最紧迫的社会和环境挑战，例如珊瑚礁的保护和恢复。Seacore 是一个由科学家和其他相关方组成的非营利性全球网络，他们正在制造陶瓷种植单元，有些看起来像小型的忍者飞镖，上面覆盖着珊瑚幼虫，从船上投放，在受损珊瑚礁的缝隙中扎根并重新繁衍生态系统。他们正在使用 3D 打印和快速原型制作来确定最佳的材料和设计组合
for the seating units. For example, they learned that it has to be rough enough for the corals to settle on an attach, but smooth enough that it's not a good location for other organisms like sponges and algae that can take over and crowd out the coral. Learn more about that project from Autodesk's Redshift, which tells the stories about the future of making things across architecture, engineering, construction, infrastructure, and manufacturing at Autodesk.com slash Redshift. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Emmett Fitzgerald. Mix and Tech Production by Sheree Fusef, Music by Sean Riel. Katie Mingle is the senior producer. Kurt Colstead is the digital director.
用于这些种植单元。例如，他们了解到它必须足够粗糙，以便珊瑚能够定居和附着，但又要足够光滑，以免成为海绵和藻类等其他生物的理想场所，因为这些生物会占据空间并挤走珊瑚。从 Autodesk 的 Redshift 了解更多关于该项目的信息，它讲述了建筑、工程、施工、基础设施和制造领域未来制造的故事，网址为 Autodesk.com/Redshift。《99% Invisible》本周由 Emmett Fitzgerald 制作。混音和技术制作由 Sheree Fusef 完成，音乐由 Sean Riel 创作。Katie Mingle 是高级制作人。Kurt Colstead 是数字总监。
The rest of the team includes senior editor Delaney Hall, Avery Trouffman, Taren Mazza, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Lee, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, an independent collective of the most innovative shows
团队的其他成员包括高级编辑 Delaney Hall、Avery Trouffman、Taren Mazza、Joe Rosenberg、Vivian Lee 以及我 Roman Mars。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，在加州奥克兰市中心美丽的 Radio Row 制作。《99% Invisible》是 PRX 旗下 RadioTopia 的成员，这是一个由最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体
in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show in joint discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI orc, or on Instagram, Tumblr and Reddit too. But if you're thinking this episode would be even better if I was looking at pretty pictures of rockfish, well we've got you covered at nettynipi.org. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在所有播客中。请在 radiotopia.fm 找到它们。你可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上关注我 @RomanMars 和节目 @99PIorg，也可以在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上关注。但如果你认为如果能看到石斑鱼的漂亮照片，这一集会更好，那么我们已经在 99pi.org 为你准备好了。来自 PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。